we have a lot of free time and in the
media that they're talking about obj and
that tandem and Baker Mayfield the next
you know Savior EP and a hot start and
deal to add on to that coach hogs talked
about a couple of times the meeting
since so God's kind of got tired of it
he was just talking about what would it
look like on paper and you know guys for
a day and basically like your sounds
good but we'll see that's our old Thomas
Ravens safety John Harbaugh pushing the
buttons and pulling the strings of the
Ravens players to make them sick of
hearing about the Browns and so far it's
working the Ravens at two and one the
Browns at one and two and the Ravens get
an opportunity to show the Browns
firsthand and up close and personal the
Ravens are a better team than the Browns
and big cat going into this game I can't
believe I'm gonna say it based on what I
thought prior to the season I think the
Ravens are the better team
hey the Ravens are the better team
because the Browns have a lot to figure
out but if anything we learned from last
night it's that these teams that are you
know maybe a playoff team they start the
season slow this week for week five
range where desperation kicks in I kind
of like the Browns I kind of like the
Browns on Sunday Mike I think they're
gonna start figuring things out remember
they're new you know there's a lot of
new pieces there
and they have to try to figure
everything you know work everything
together they have new head coach I know
he was you know working with Baker last
year they're trying to work in Odell
Beckham they're trying to work with the
bad offensive line
I think the Browns are gonna be able to
win this game just purely out of their
desperate they want it more
the Ravens feel a little bit more
comfortable and the Browns defense has
been very good this year yeah my concern
though is last night it was Doug
Peterson who has won a Super Bowl who
had been three-and-oh on short weeks
then he got Freddie kitchens and that
explanation from Monday with the play
calling gaffs in Sunday night's game
that hey I'm new at this I don't like
that hey I'm new at this I'm still
learning the ropes and that's the
problem they still are learning the
ropes so even though it is desperation
time I feel like processing adversity
recovering from a bad start I don't know
that they're going to be as good as it
now as they maybe in future years if
Freddie kitchens keeps the job so I
think the Ravens after losing at Kansas
City a game that they tried to throw
everything they could at the Chiefs to
win that game and I think they overdid
it
I think they stick to the more basic
game plan against the Browns and just go
out and show everyone that they are even
a little bit better but I think more
than a little bit better I think I've
touched down and more better than the
Browns alright let's move on to Chiefs
lines I mentioned the Chiefs beating the
Ravens the lines or - oh and one and
look the Lions the Lions of one games as
Mike Tirico said over the weekend that
in past years the Lions would not have
won they too lost those games but the
Chiefs are still the Chiefs and for the
first time in his regular season NFL
career Patrick the Holmes is playing in
a dome the over-under on his yardage
maybe 750 I mean you people just love
talking about this right Patrick my home
is playing in a dome for the first time
this is like the stat that I've heard a
million times including your internet
son my co-host he just kept on saying it
on on today's show but I think the
Chiefs are just the better team
throughout and I don't think that's a
crazy thing for me to say here the Lions
you're right they've been pressed
everyone a little bit more than we
thought - oh and one no one would have
thought the lines would be undefeated
going into this game even though they
have the tie I think lines stay close
but I think the Chiefs will win this
game just because it's so impossible to
stop Patrick mahomes for four quarters
yeah I mean I think Matt Patricia the
coach of the Lions is gonna take the
game plan that the Patriots used in the
AFC Championship game to slow things
down in the Chiefs offense force Patrick
mahomes to take what's available
underneath take away the deep stuff the
explosive plays the big quick touchdowns
but I just don't think the Lions have
the horses to implement it the way the
Patriots did and then I'll have the
offense to match touchdown for touchdown
late in the game if they need to and
what you just said I mean you're right
they're probably will use the same game
plan but remember that AFC championship
game what Pat from ur homes did in the
second half the Chiefs you cannot stop
the Chiefs offense for four quarters and
there will be a moment where they'll
have to trade touchdowns with Patrick
mahomes and I just don't see it
happening
Patriots Bills on Sunday the fourth
annual identified flying object game in
Buffalo
every time we have this game we think
this is the chance for the bills to show
that they're for real they're three and
oh I don't buy it
I gotta see it before I'll believe it
the Patriots are still the Patriots
they've dominated everyone they've
played yes their opponents are a
combined oh and nine so far I still like
the Patriots going to Buffalo and remind
everyone why they are the best team in
the NFL
what identified unidentified flying
objects you're talking about are you one
of those area 51 weirdos no no no no
that's it's a different kind of weirdo
that has to show up for these games with
the identified flying object but anyway
who do you like ah I think the Patriots
are win this game I like the bills I
think their defense is very very good
this is going to be the toughest test
for the Patriots in the season because
they have not played a good defense yet
and it's it's gonna be a fun atmosphere
I love bills mafia I love the City of
Buffalo I just don't know if that
offense is there in the fourth quarter
against what could be the best secondary
probably is the best secondary in the
NFL with the Patriots so I think it's
gonna be close
I think the bills will have a chance but
the Patriots are the Patriots for a
reason so I would probably take the
Patriots if you made me pick yeah and I
agree with you although this is gonna be
their first real test this season but I
think they're good enough to pass any
test that comes their way
Panthers in tech since Kyle Allen gets
his second start he looked very good
last week against the Cardinals the
Texans are sneaky 2 & 1
I mean just because they mortgage their
future that means they got plenty of
cash right now they've got Laremy Tunsil
they've got Kenny Stills out of those
trades where they gave up multiple
first-round picks and the Texans in
position to separate from the pack in
the AFC South I think it's going to come
down to the Texans and the Colts and I
think they're gonna know three and one
after this one yeah I was impressed with
the Texans going to LA and having that
second half where they look like it
could have you know gotten away from
them and deshaun Watson in that offense
rattles off 20 straight points that was
a very like non Texan game do you know
what I mean because I think we both are
in the similar spot where we've
criticized the Texans in the past we've
always thought they're a nice team but
never for real I never really thought
hey this team can go on the road and win
a game where
down at halftime like that that game in
LA on Sunday that kind of proves
something to me that this Texans team
might be a little bit different than the
Texans of the past so I think they'll
take care of business at home and I just
I'm gonna view the Texas a little
differently this year just based off
what they did even if you look at Monday
night to open the season to go
toe-to-toe and you know with the Saints
in the dome an electric atmosphere
I think this Texas team has a little bit
more resolved than ones that we've seen
in the last few years the one key to
watch with the Texans as the season
unfolds at some point - Shaun Watson has
got to get rid of the ball sooner we
blame the offensive line for him getting
hit so often he holds on to the ball for
way too long he's got to start making
decisions faster and when he gets to
that point he will be up in the top five
to seven quarterbacks in the NFL
all right Washington at the Giants the
Daniel Jones Show
he has his home debut at MetLife Stadium
against one of the most dysfunctional
teams in the NFL I quote you all the
time in relation to that franchise
dysfunctional teams do dysfunctional
things whether it's not going with your
rookie quarterback when you should or
stirring the Gatorade with a sleeve of
cups wrapped in plastic but I like the
Giants to win at home I can't believe
I'm saying it because I didn't think I
like the Giants at all this year but
Daniel Jones gives them something very
different than what we saw with Eli
Manning yeah that saying came about for
when the Cubs were still very
dysfunctional organization and they had
a bunch of kids sign a card for Ron
Santo would passed that year and then
they found the Rondo card in the
dumpster behind Wrigley and it was a big
story about it so that's my
dysfunctional teams do dysfunctional
things saying I'm gonna go Zig on
everyone zag here I'm gonna take the
Redskins I think the Redskins
are not good which is not that was that
was not a hot take right there I realize
how stupid that sounded their defense is
good
Daniel Jones had a great first game a
great first impression I'm always
nervous about the the getting up that
high and then having to do it all again
and everyone's seen you for a week and
you have to basically say I'm going to
be this guy we can we
out I think there's always a little lull
and how about the fact that say Quan
Barclays out I know that they won the
game against the Bucks that is a huge
deal for this offense and knowing the
Redskins can plan for no se Quan
Barclays changes how they can they can
go against Daniel Jones how they can
game plan sacrum Barclays leaves the
game against the Bucks it's a lot harder
to gameplan in the middle of the game
than all week
I think the Redskins are gonna win this
game like short week for Washington and
dysfunction abounds for that
organization so I'm sticking with the
Giants how about this last one before we
take a break
Titans are 1 & 2 Falcons are 1 & 2 is
the loser of this one done you just did
it I love it it's the loser leaves town
game Mike it's a loser leaves town loser
leaves town also I don't know if you
heard but the Falcons are my pinky bet
for the year so if the Atlanta Falcons
win the Superbowl I will cut off the tip
of my pinky I think they are done I am
done with the Falcons I'm done with Matt
Ryan I have a rule that I made up this
year if Mike Vrabel is being doubted
that's when you take Mike variables so I
think the Titans will step up for this
game I think they're gonna win this game
and then next week they'll probably
score 3 points in Marcus Mariota will
look terrible but I think they'll show
up for this game on Sunday I mean you
know throw throw out the play books the
film the analytics and everything else
you've hit the nail on the head
the Titans win when they're supposed to
lose and they lose when they're supposed
to win and that's the Titans and once
you accept that you can understand how
things work and Marcus Mariota knows
he's in danger of being benched there
was a moment last week where it felt
like Mike Vrabel was thinking about
putting Ryan Tannehill in the game
Marcus Mariota had no sense of urgency
down two scores late in the game against
Jacksonville they've had extra time to
get ready for this one they're not
supposed to win it and I think that
makes it even more likely that the
Titans win I think your your your
pinkies gonna be safe for the same
reasons we said earlier that the Eagles
couldn't afford to go to 1 & 3
the Falcons can't afford to go 1 in 3 in
that conference with all those great
teams they're gonna be in second and
third place in their divisions taking
the 5 and the 6 seed the Falcons are
gonna be done I'm not going to join you
in the pinky swear thing I'd say you
know it's a dangerous habit that you're
getting into because eventually you're
gonna have to cut off the tip of your
pinky if you do it every year and you're
not gonna get lucky every year but I
this year your pinky safe yeah I don't
know why you said the NFC South is some
like murderers row of tea no the NSA the
NFC oh god I got it yeah I just I'm sick
of the Falcons I always invest in them
if you will you can figure that out
weakly I invest in them and I think Matt
Ryan and Julio Jones will always show up
and they have all that sizzle and it
just I'm done with them I can't I can't
stand watching the Falcons offense you
know fail in the red zone and Dan Quinn
play conservative football I just can't
watch it so I think the Titans win and I
think I am safe that the Falcons will
not win the Super Bowl this year this is
big-boy football Chicago knows that too
so you know and we're not gonna have any
extra motivation that Chicago doesn't
have it's gonna go in there with two
heavyweights and one's gonna emerge with
a victory Kirk Cousins Sankat cousins
things as he gets ready to take on mitts
true Biscay having the beard does not
make it any better by the way the team
that wins this game at Soldier Field on
Sunday in the big spot CBS for 25 p.m.
Eastern it's gonna be the team that is
able to best hide their quarterback
right get somebody else on the offense
to make things happen that's your ticket
to winning because if you put it on your
quarterback whether you're Minnesota or
Chicago you're not gonna win the game
there's the analysis no I agree I mean
if you look at the Vikings this year the
two wins they've had Kirk Cousins thrown
the ball 32 times the one loss they had
he threw a 31 times do the math it's not
hard to figure out that the the goal of
both offenses is to basically try to run
the ball play defense and hope your
quarterback doesn't make a lot of
mistakes
Mike four-and-twenty I think it's four
in 24 Kirk Cousins all-time against
winning teams whoa
yeah well this is the opportunity and
again it's all about hiding Kirk Cousins
riding Dalvin cook and I don't know how
much you've seen Dalvin cook this year
there's something different about him
it's man among boys type stuff every
time he gets the ball he explodes to the
second level and often beyond he's
averaging six point nine yards per carry
and the Bears don't have a team Hicks I
mean that's really the question if he
can't play on the short week with the
knee injury
that takes away one of the guys who
would help bottle things up in the
middle and keep Dalvin cook from getting
through although most of his damage has
been on those outside run plays where
Hakeem Hicks wouldn't matter anyway I
have a problem with your use of short
week that you've kept on using short
wheeshes winter short week is when a
team plays on Thursday not one a team
points Monday to Sunday
hey Monday Monday and travel home and a
tough game a game that was closer than
it should have been that has a factor
look it up the short week Monday road
team this is the Monday night road team
struggles on the following Sunday look
it up did you watch that game that was
closer than it should be and it wasn't
it was a tough game what what are we
watching yeah was it yeah it was hey it
got interesting in the fourth quarter I
thought it should have been you you have
to agree with me it should have been 45
to 3 that was an embarrassment that the
Bears let washing it back into the game
oh I see what you did in there no no no
that's fine the Bears are gonna win on
Sunday I'll guarantee it I got the
Vikings ok great guarantee you put your
will you put the tip of your pinky on
that one no we'll do a steak dinner ok
sure well I'll transfer you to you the
one that sim still owes me if I'm
covered in oil that means I have to go
to dinner with Simms absolutely not
Cowboys it's ain't Sunday Night Football
can teddy bridgewater continue what he
did last week where they had 265 yards
of offense in Seattle Seattle had more
than 500 yards somehow the Saints won
can they knock off the Cowboys are you
gonna visualize are we gonna visualize
well close your eyes but what are we
visualizing here we're visualizing the
Saints home uniforms where we
visualizing the Cowboys road uniforms
I'm gonna tell it to you we're gonna
visualize the dome we're going to
visualize the whistle guy you know the
big whistle that he wears on his head
the guy who's who has the big ring on
his head we're gonna visualize the sound
of the dome we're gonna see it's gonna
be simply some people dressed as
referees with with dark glasses on yucks
will have that the Cowboys Road jerseys
which don't feel as good they don't feel
it they wear that weird blue thing where
it doesn't the sleeves don't really
match I think the Saints are gonna win
this game I like them I
you know they feel confident in teddy
bridgewater couldn't have asked for a
better start for teddy bridgewater by
the way to get spotted 14 points by your
kick where do you know special teams in
your defense he now has a little
confidence
I think the Saints can win this game the
Cowboys have played no one and I think
the Cowboys are good but I always am
nervous about the team that's played
absolutely no one and we anoint them the
best team in the league yeah I don't
disagree with that I mean I've picked
the Cowboys but I know how salty the
Saints were last year after they went to
Dallas and lost that game that kind of
you know slammed the window shut on us
assuming the Saints would be a Super
Bowl team although they still almost
recovered and made it back they were
dominant until that game the Thursday
after Thanksgiving against Dallas and
they have been waiting for the Cowboys
to come to the dome ever since then all
right real quick
Cardinals Seahawks is there any doubt
the Seahawks mop up the floor with them
nope nope I'll actually get back to this
game in our drafts so note no doubt in
my mind
Buccaneers Rams rant I feel like there's
a window for the Bucs but I think the
Rams win I just close the window there
you go
all right all right we'll be right back
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports